mort au dictateur
femme vit liberté ces slogans résonnent
dans les rues iraniennes alors que la
révolte entame son troisième mois et
s'intensifie depuis 3 jours
des coups de feu dans le métro de
Téhéran
une femme qui s'écroule sous des coups
de matraque les Iraniens défilent
autorités
le régime riposte avec encore plus de
violence
[Musique]
les rues commerçantes sont désertes
quand elles ne sont pas prises d'assaut
par les manifestants
un peu partout en Iran leur est à
l'opposition
nous voulons un pays libre sans
oppression et où les droits de la
personne sont respectées nous confie
cette lycéenne de 18 ans
car si des manifestants tombent sous les
balles d'autres sont en prisonniers on
connaît pas leur condition carcérale
mais on peut deviner est-ce qu'il y a eu
viol certainement qui a eu brutalité
certainement qui a eu de la torture et à
la fois vous avez la torture physique
et vous avez aussi la torture
psychologique
des sévices que la génialda arazafli 19
ans avait subi en prison et qu'elle a
raconté dimanche et le retrouver sans
vie peu de temps après sa libération des
clients il y a un foyer de contestation
supplémentaire qui se crée et cette
révolte au départ était la révolte de
femmes éduquées dans les villes est
devenu un mouvement à la fois mixte
homme et femme cette étudiante nous
avoue que chaque jour elle brave
l'obligation de se voiler même la peur
tout le visage de cette répression le
mouvement actuel a une portée
universelle qui transcende les classes
sociales qui transcendent les
générations et c'est ça qui est
intéressant
on peut penser que le régime est en
train de jouer sa survie par rapport à
un lit de révolte qui est de plus en
plus fort mais il n'y a pas de leader et
donc le régime espère qu'il va y avoir
une lassitude de la révolte
pour l'instant comme le scands ces
jeunes le sang verser ne sera pas vain
car ils sont convaincus que le pouvoir
sera renversé
[Musique]
un pays partagé entre l'Espérance et
l'inquiétude entre un régime extrêmement
conservateur et une jeunesse ouverture
le monde ici Yasmine Hayat Radio-Canada
Montréal